the next question that i want to have a
look at was part e so read it with me it
says given that x and y are two
unequal
positive
real numbers okay so a lot of
information already just packed into
those few words
show that my laser point is still not
working that the average of the squares
of x and y
okay that's a lot the average of the
squares of x and y
is greater than
the square of the average of x and y
okay average of the squares is greater
than the square of the average okay
feels a bit like am gm inequality esque
and it is related to that but it is not
exactly the same because um yeah the
squares are a little bit different okay
so how do we deal with this with proof
question and this inequality okay let's
have a look
the first thing and this is part e that
i'm doing at the moment so just write
that down the first thing is i need to
convert all of that verbal language into
an algebraic inequality because then i
can start manipulating it right so the
first thing the question said was about
the
the sum sorry the average of the squares
the average of the squares so x squared
plus y squared
when you want to find the average of
those two numbers you add them and then
you divide by two so that is the average
of the squares and then what we want to
do is square the average so that's
taking the average between x and y is x
plus y on two so that's x plus y
on 2
and then we need to take that whole
thing the entire average and square it
right now what we've been let's just put
this in here
what we've been asked to prove so i'll
write rtep required to prove is that the
first expression is greater than the
second expression this is what i'm after
so one of the classic ways when you've
got all these squares going on right a
classic thing is to prove or can i use
the properties of the squares
algebraically to show that i'm above
zero or less than zero or those kinds of
things so i'm going to pull out a
classic trick and just get everything
over to one side make it greater than or
lesser than zero and then see if i can
prove that using the properties of
squares so you can see here if i am
exceptionally lazy just grab this what
i'm going to do is i'm going to imagine
subtracting that right hand term from
both sides so that leaves me with zero
on the right hand side this is what i'm
going to try and work on right so as my
proof i'm going to consider
let's zoom in zoom out rather
the left hand side
the left hand side is going to be equal
to all of this like so
and what i want to do i guess is take
this pair of fractions and sort of
smoosh them together in a way that i get
squares out for everything
and hopefully those squares will enable
me to say well the whole thing is going
to be greater than or equal to or not
greater than or equal to just strictly
greater than zero and that's actually
going to be a bit of a sneaky thing
which we struggled to do but i'm getting
ahead of myself let's work on combining
this together
you can see here um this right hand
fraction it's going to be sort of x plus
y all squared on 4. so
i might as well sort of work towards
getting common denominators right so
this is going to be equal to
2x squared plus 2 y squared take away
and then here comes the x plus y all
squared it will be x squared plus 2xy
plus
y squared and all of that is being
divided by 4. so in fact rather than
draw some big enormous fraction i'm a
bit lazy to do that so i'm just going to
say all of that divided by 4 happy times
you can see here i'm clearly going to
get some like terms here so there's my x
squareds and there are y squareds so
what am i going to end up with i'm going
to have i don't need a big prerequisites
anymore just a single x squared
just a single y squared
and then i've got just watch out for it
a minus 2 x y
from that divided by 4. now hopefully
you recognize this result because you
can say wait i can factorize this thing
this is a binomial that has been squared
right because it's
this squared this squared and then
double the product in the middle right
so this is clearly just going to be x
minus y
all squared divided by 4.
do i have what i need well i think i'm
pretty much there i just need to put a
little bit of extra
requirement here right
is this going to be greater than 0
because that's what i want as you can
see the answer is yes it is but i need
to provide the reasoning for that
reasoning number one okay if i can say
x and y are real which i know from the
question therefore i know that this
thing has to be non-negative so
therefore it's greater than or equal to
zero that's a plus
so i'm going to say but
x and y are real so therefore that tells
me that x minus y all squared the
smallest it can be a 0 right
however i don't want this thing to be
equal to 0 because then i would need to
have this is wrong so don't write it i'd
have to have a boundary included there
and that's not what i've been required
to prove so if that's what i don't want
i actually need more information it's
not enough that they're just real
numbers so let's go back to the question
and see if it gives any clues
one of those things that i underlined it
said given that x and y are two unequal
positive real numbers so i've already
appealed to the fact that they're real
that was good but not enough the extra
piece of information i need is that
they're unequal
on equal so i've underlined that in red
so let's bring that over here and say
and
x
and y are not equal so x can't equal y
which means this x minus y that i've got
up in here right that has to be not
equal to zero so therefore when you
square it because they're different
numbers right you still can't be equal
to zero so you can see what this tells
you is that your greater than or equal
to zero it equals zero but what this
tells you is i can exclude the zero okay
so therefore i can say
ta-da the left-hand side has to be not
just greater than or equal to but
strictly greater than 0. so therefore
i-e i've got this result here
like so that was the left hand side it's
greater than or equal to zero and wow
i'm being so lazy today
therefore i can just add that
x plus y or squared to both sides to the
right hand side one of both sides and
that's the result that i was required to
prove so
there you go i'm finished the reason i
really wanted to highlight this question
is because this sequence of logic here
was very very poorly done students knew
that they had to kind of go in this
direction but they just kind of fudged
it it's not dissimilar to this question
here where we got a velocity function
which had a plus or minus and people
were like oh i'll just choose the
positive one because it's convenient to
me
no you can't just choose one because
it's convenient you actually have to
provide the reasoning that goes
underneath it so please be really really
careful